what up space fam golsan here from anime
opera i'm back at it again to discuss
the latest crazy updates in the dragon
ball super story and this chapter was
very weird but also very hyped so make
sure to stay tuned for this one if you
do enjoy these dragon ball super chapter
reviews and want to keep them coming you
know what to do child saying within and
smash that like button with no mercy
smashing his goku energy and passing his
yamcha energy so you know choose wisely
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future dragon ball super videos and
updates now without further ado let's
jump into its spoilers and all so this
chapter continues with the fight against
evolved gas and goku where obviously
goku can only stall and doesn't actually
have the power to beat him yet vegeta
gotta power up this arc and epic one but
goku still didn't which is something to
keep in mind and the way dragon ball
usually works is that goku defeats the
strong opponent at the end of the day
and although i wish it was vegeta this
time around it seems like they might be
going for goku yet again but more on
that later goku's gotta resort to some
tricks because of the nature of the
power gap between them he's using
instant teleportation and gas is
following him but he's not as skilled at
it as goku is we got more comedy in the
middle of this fight than i expected in
one case mud gets poured on gas as they
are teleporting and goku even chides him
for being so reckless we see monaka and
it's clear that goku is using the key
signatures he recognizes to teleport
from far away place to far away place
while gas doesn't know these people so
he can only chase after goku he then
appears before the galactic king who's
having a bath this guy always gets
wrapped up in naked jokes and this time
gas straight up falls into the bathtub
goku is getting a kick out of this
saying it's the perfect time for a bath
after the mud incident it's nice to see
that even if he's not stronger now goku
is not helpless and is actually using
his skill and experience to embarrass
the stronger gas in different ways back
to vegeta who realizes that goku is
buying time by jumping from planet to
planet while the heaters are wondering
where they are and decide to get a look
at gas's position via his tracker next
thing we know goku has brought gas into
the galactic prison cass gets a good
kick on goku but then the chapter takes
the weirdest turn dude as goku is asking
if gas is right to admit that goku is
better than him at instant teleportation
the prisoners start talking they want
gas to let them out but he doesn't
thinking he doesn't need their help so
what happens the prisoners bring up how
the first time they met gas gas wet
himself when i was first reading this i
was like really that's the approach
they're going for and you can tell how
childish at heart gas still is despite
his power because he actually gets riled
up saying he did not urinate on himself
if anyone ever says you wet yourself you
just ignore them and carry on doing what
you were doing you don't stop and have a
pointless back and forth about it but
that's exactly what gas does the
prisoners see this struck a nerve and
start pretty much calling him a coward
saying he totally wet himself and he was
even calling to his brother to help him
and saying he was scared at this point
hilariously even goku is like is that
true i've never seen is that spelled
with two z's but props to the manga
translators for getting creative you
have arguably the strongest dude in the
world getting super upset saying there
was no urination involved and then the
prisoner says something weirder refusing
to drop it he asks what was that wet
stain about does your tribe cry out of
their crotches and the other prisoner is
like sick burn man
this like strange sounds like i traveled
back in time to my elementary school
playground i wonder if people still
actually talk like this but anyways gas
keeps getting more and more heated and
finally admits that in fact he did wet
himself although he says it doesn't
count because it was only a few drops
because he was holding it back for so
long any fear that this dude might have
instilled in us has completely
evaporated at this point i'm not saying
every villain has to be fearsome but
they clearly decide to focus on comedy
rather than a cool intimidating villain
here anyways after goku is like dang you
really did weight yourself huh we move
on to the heaters figuring out that they
are at the galactic prison and ella
calls him an idiot probably guessing
what's happening then goku and gas
teleport once again and goku harps on
the other thing gas was criticized for
asking so you only do everything your
big brother says for goku this is
ridiculous because gas is way stronger
can make his own choices and yet gas
chooses to just obey his brother ellick
is the true villain in this arc even if
he's not the strongest and at this point
gas just feels like a glorified henchman
he even says he seeks power for alex
sake alone he wants to make the heaters
a supreme organization the universe and
that's just because his brother wants
that it's interesting when gas says he
was once the weakest among them and he
credits elek for raising him to this
level and because of that he says he
would do anything for him goku then
raises the question that i've been
emphasizing for a while whether gas can
trust alec goku points out that his
brother almost killed him a while back
and you gotta appreciate the raddest
reference here man i miss raditz goku
just tells gas to watch his back and
it's good advice for such a childish and
naive character back to the heaters and
they plan to finish off everyone left on
the planet because they're already half
dead so monaeto and granola look like
they're in big trouble as goku continues
teleporting he realizes he's badly hurt
from defending and knows he can't play
defense much longer he suddenly gets
excited and teleports to where whis is
he clearly sends this key goku then
tells whis to watch gas for a second and
then pieces out and teleports backwards
quickly all the way to the planet cereal
and he did it so fast that now he's too
far away for the inexperienced gas to
sense him in other words gas is stuck as
goku appears in the nick of time to save
monaeto and granola from the heaters
whis looks amused as usual and tells gas
that goku is back to serial and it's too
great a distance for gas to warp
directly there i love how goku played
him here despite being weaker no one can
say goku is stupid when it comes to
battles what i didn't necessarily like
is that whis appears to actually tell
gas the right direction to planet cereal
which i feel like he didn't have to do
gas then starts going there by flying
with superhuman speed another highlight
is that the oracle fish says who was
that which can be read as a funny moment
but also suggests that gas is not
actually the strongest mortal fighter in
the universe that he was prophesizing
about the strongest warrior that will
soon rise may in fact be vegeta or as it
suggested by the end of the chapter goku
that's how i read it but let me know if
you have some other thoughts on this in
the comments or if i missed anything who
do you think is the strongest warrior
that will soon rise the one of prophecy
back to goku who takes granola and them
to safety oatmeal is like a star wars
robot pet now and helps them out the
heaters let them go because elek knows
they are no match for goku right now
then through a communication device we
splanted on goku they talk whis is not
happy with his dessert time being
interrupted but goku brings up a great
point saying he was just the right
distance away and you gas would have to
behave around someone like whis then wii
says gas is approaching him at breakneck
speed and again why you have to tell him
the direction whis not cool we shouldn't
have to help goku obviously but he
didn't have to help gas either whis says
gas will reach them in 20 minutes so
they got about enough time for one anime
episode that hopefully includes a
bardock flashback when naito says it's
not enough time to heal granola again
emphasizing that goku or vegeta will
have to step it up we get some very
interesting stuff here whis is wondering
how goku is doing and goku explains he
can't keep his heart calm the way whis
does and we says yeah since angels are
fundamentally different life forms from
goku who is a saiyan as we know then we
says it is up to goku to discover his
own unique version of ultra instinct he
says listen to the voice within you deep
down what are you really and then as if
to answer that question monito
interrupts saying hey son of bardock
there's something i have to show you so
it seems clear that goku's next version
of ultra instinct will be tied to his
saiyan nature which is very exciting
because it would be an opportunity to
revamp the super saiyan 4 look or at
least for goku to take on more cool
saiyan slash ape looking attributes i
know for many people super saiyan 4 is
their favorite design so this could be a
perfect instance to draw inspiration
from it in a canon series we know dragon
ball is based off of journey to the west
and goku is based off of the monkey king
so combining monkey attributes as well
as god attributes like the monkey king
does would be a very logical progression
from this point we find out that bardock
scouter recorded his battle with gas
back in the day so now our guys can
actually watch it and figure out how to
beat gas although it doesn't work at
first oatmeal ends up being able to play
the audio we briefly get the heaters
calling gas the ultimate being now and
then we return to our guys listening to
the recording goku actually hears his
father's voice which is crazy to think
about as we hear bardock say to monaeto
that he and granola have to stay alive
goku gets a flashback of bardock and his
mom telling him he has to stay alive the
blocked off memory and history awakens
something goku and then we see what we
can only assume is a new power and at
least the beginning of the new form i
mentioned it's very reminiscent of when
a saiyan looks at the moon and starts
their great ape transformation and that
appears to be it for this epic chapter
for some reason viz also gave us some
scenes from the next chapter which will
be a flashback and showing us the
bardock vs granola fight which i'm super
hyped about as well they obviously don't
give us any huge reveals in this teaser
but gas does give bardock props for
being a powerful fighter and to his
credit he does kick gas around a bit
however he's not super optimistic saying
he'll slow gas down rather than stop him
and it doesn't look good for him which
leads me to believe that he might awaken
a new form to stop gas bardock even
mentions that gas is a monster at this
point and his attacks didn't even
scratch gas and gas as usual wants to
win to keep his brother happy and that
is it for this one very hype we have
bardock's fight to look forward to and
goku's new power-up which i am very glad
to say looks like it will call back to
his roots as a saiyan let me know your
thoughts on this chapter who was your
mvp if you did enjoy this review and
want to keep them coming you know what
to do chill the same within and smash
that like button smashing his goku
energy and passing his yamcha energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
dragon ball super videos and updates and
until next time see ya space cowboys